hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
is the 29th in September and I've got
your daily dose of GameSpot knees the
xbox one could be finding its footing in
the console war particularly since it
recently outsold the ps4 in the UK the
Xbox one has now tops the weekly UK
hardware charts thanks to a marketing
course from FIFA 15 on Xbox one which
boosted sales 155 percent week on week
according to retail sources on top of
that our British friends got a 20-pound
discount recently as part of a limited
time only promotion season 15 has
accounted for eighty percent of all
retail game sales in the UK last week
and it also helped to boost ps4 sales by
about a cent in more news bad games
where you kick a ball around pro
evolution soccer 2015 is going to render
at 1080p on ps4 and 720p on xbox one yes
it's yet more resolution in youth but
here's the lowdown for those of you who
want the details Konami announced the
performance settings via their official
webpage and added that both editions
will run at 60 frames per second the
game was built with Konami Fox engine
the same tech used for Metal Gear Solid
5 ground zeroes and the phantom pain PS
2015 is shipping on November 11 in the
US and November 13 in the UK finally
I've got an uncharted 4 thing for you
and it's Nathan Drake's face but like
super close up if you're hankering to
find out what your favorite adventuring
smart-talking here will look like in the
upcoming action game lead game designer
Kurt Morgan or has given us another look
uncharted for a thief's end won't be
coming out until next year but Morgan or
captured tweeted the preview image shot
and upped by captioning it strikers
looking at nextgen as [ __ ] the shot was
taken at the Naughty Dog 30th
anniversary art exhibit in California
the handsome sob is looking a little
worse for wear but pretty damn detailed
and still pretty similar to what he
looked like in the teaser trailer that
was revealed at
three this year ask you a question of
the day let me know what you think of
Nathan Drake's new next jealous look and
whether you're a fan of the Uncharted
series that is it for your Monday
episode you can check out more newsy
things like character creation in the
new Dragon eight on gamespot right now
and I will catch you same time and place
tomorrow